c'est difficile mais jouer une scène
comme ça c'est vraiment le composition
la ride en cc oui j'ai appris mon texte
c'est pas des thérapies orales répétées
plein de fois je vais essayer ensemble
plusieurs fois avant vous les lieux mais
nous sommes ensemble mais ça c'est moi
seul qui dit ça il faut être discret par
jour scolaire par exemple quand on en
voit si on pensait tous que c'est pas
vrai mais quand on en voit si on dit que
vous êtes ensemble par exemple ça
m'énerve tellement bien le temps
encombrants smaïn parce que le but ce
n'est pas les mauvaises qui s'est mangé
tellement de râteaux je disais en
préparant s'était enfin j'aimerais
dancing à bars obasi vars alors qu'ils
allaient voir les filles vous voulez
danser non il mais qu'il menait après
les volets d' anciens disaient oui et
c'était toujours le suivant calais
droite dans celle de la fille à montjean
les prix des râteaux à oui oui monsieur
râteau la main sur un taux national 3
richer non c'est vrai quoi j'ai pris des
claques
ouais j'en ai donné aussi c'est la vie
maintenant c'est fini tout ça maintenant
je tenais ma refuse la preuve
mais vous avez ce qui est vrai en
revanche c'est que vous avez été quand
même en 94 à petit ami de johnny
hallyday c'est vrai ça a duré longtemps
trois heures
les jambes le 10 janvier m les jeux
s'invitent à des tout est pourquoi pas
ça une johnny je viens de voir d'autres
a jamais rencontré de près mais qu'elle
en a eu quelques-uns c'est le problème
je me souviens pas par exemple de passer
si je me souviens très bien du tout à
fait sérieusement ça dure et combien de
temps alors parce que j'étais un mois et
demi ah ouais quand même
mais février à vis etc sinon vous avez
déclaré au sujet de votre relation avec
johnny hallyday
j'en ai tiré ni avantage ni inconvénient
c'est pas très sympa mais aussi parce
qu'au départ
vous savez quand quand vous êtes jeune
dans le métier à ce moment là j'étais
mannequin je suis toujours du mannequin
d'ailleurs mais c'est vrai que quand
vous êtes mannequin ou que vous entrez
un petit peu dans un domaine public
si vous avez une aventure à quelqu'un de
célèbre au début de votre carrière ont
dit oui c'est un coup médiatique où elle
le fait parce qu'elle espère que ça va
lui apporter quelque chose mais c'est
vrai que c'est de toute façon c'est
toujours le contraire qui se produit je
vous ai rien inventé du tout donc non sa
part s'était appelé ces traîtres de très
bons moments moi j'ai pas de nom mais
jamais tout à fait non c'est quelqu'un
de gentil c'est quelqu'un de gentil que
je trouve intelligent charismatique et
c'est vrai que ça s'est passé comme ça
et comme d'autres hommes quand on
traverse et ma vie j'en garde pas de
nine mauvais souvenir d'une bons
souvenirs je pense que c'est une
expérience ça vous habite petit à petit
puis vous apprennent et des choses
conneries là donc ça veut dire que ça
veut dire que linda attend le grand
amour oui si j'ai bien compris et les
hommes mariés ça vous dérange mans non
mais ça peut déranger votre femme bien
vu j'ai essayé mais je crois que c'est
un peu galère
oui je suppose et s'il donc c'est en
fait vous avez été connue déjà depuis
1992 j'ai été miss pays de loire en 91
g/t mr atlantique ans
flessel j'étais mystoires a senti que le
16 juin 91 c'est à dire 7 le film sort
le 16 juin vous suivez là parce que vous
aviez quand vous étiez je me souviens
très très bien ben on s'en souvient pas
on va regarder faire magnéto 92 miss
pays de loire
ouais
là
fabrice delloye mais selon m
avec 75 imaginaire 18 ans elle est
étudiante
elle s'appelle linda hardy c'est la
nouvelle miss france 1992 alors vous
avez donc 18 ans samuel vincent son de
leurs escales sevran vous êtes des
libyens mais c'est parce que c'est bon
qu'il écrite
il venait d'avoir 18 ans et cela dès ce
soir vécu en ce qui me concerne c'est
déjà julien lepers qui commandent
toujours là julien devient drôle de look
en main vous êtes beaucoup mieux
maintenant un geste d'accord alors fait
je vous dis qu'est ce qui s'est passé
c'est sûr que j'ai les cheveux
naturellement très très bouclés
oui j'avais les cheveux longs et pendant
l'élection de miss france ya quelques
jours une préparation que l'on connaît
où elle est la capitale de la france des
questions qu'il faut savoir
durant ces quelques jours de préparation
donc moi je me balade séjour avec mes
cheveux très bouclés je faisais pas trop
gaffes et la miss france 91 mais mme de
fontenay lui disait ans qu'est ce que
vous aimez bien 10 et moi j'aime bien
miss pays de loire pour une petite
anecdote je pense que madame de fontenay
sera pas fâché et
on allait avec un homme vous voyez
toujours avec ce look un peu parce qu'on
pense souvent que d'origine étrangère
chpa française à 10,0 non faire rabat
sera pas miss france a fait un round et
puis trois jours avant l'élection lors
des préparations les comme j'avais cette
masse de cheveux qui me couvrir
complètement le visage
les coiffeurs ont décidé de me dégager
visage donc à un tel point que et voilà
quoi est ce jour là même de médias ben
voilà mademoiselle hardy enfin vous
ressembler à quelque chose vous allez
essayer la deuxième on vous embrasse
malentendu n'exagérons rien quand même